Bonjour, curieuses et curieux ! Comme
vous pouvez le voir,  je ne suis pas au
studio mais chez moi,
confinée comme beaucoup d'entre nous en
cette période et mes pensées vont
particulièrement à ceux qui n'ont pas le
privilège de pouvoir travailler depuis
chez eux,  ni même d'avoir un chez eux
tout court, et aussi tout
particulièrement aux soignants et à
toutes celles et ceux qui luttent en ce
moment même contre la maladie.
Donc,  dans ce contexte un peu particulier,
je vous présente une version un peu plus
légères de Zeste de  Science,  faite un peu avec
les moyens du bord. Donc nous allons
prendre juste quelques minutes pour
parler de science,  nous évader un peu et
puis nourrir notre curiosité.
Alors c'est parti !
En me baladant sur la chaîne youtube du CNRS,  j'ai trouvé ça :
Ils sont trop mignons !
Ces petits écureuils canadiens ne sont pas seulement très mignons
et fans de beurre de cacahuètes mais ça, on y reviendra plus tard
ils nous en apprennent beaucoup sur les effets de l'environnement social
et en particulier
sur le stress qu'il peut provoquer.
Bon. Je vous explique. Alors déjà ces petits
écureuils terrestres s'appellent des spermophiles
parce qu'ils mangent des graines. Ils
hibernent
et la colonie étudiée par les scientifiques de Strasbourg
est installée dans le parc provincial de Ship river, en Alberta.
Depuis 27 ans, des scientifiques suivent ces animaux tout au long de cette saison de reproduction
et comptabilise méthodiquement agression et coopération entre les individus.
Et ils ont montré que les femelles sont
moins agressives envers leurs proches
parentes, mère, fille, soeur,
qu'envers des individus d'autres familles
avec une petite subtilité :  si les femelles proches
sont plus âgées et dominantes,
il y encore beaucoup d'agressions.
Ce qui veut dire qu'en gros,  si c'est ta mère,  ça
marche pas très bien.
Afin de mieux comprendre les effets de
cet environnement social sur l'organisme
les scientifiques effectuent aussi des
prélèvements d'ADN, de sang et de crottes
en attirant les spermophiles avec du
beurre de cacahuète
et je les comprends !
Leur but : Comparer le taux de stress de
l'organisme à la composition de
l'environnement social et aux données
comportementales de terrain. Pour cela, en
connaissant l'identité de tous les
individus de la communauté,  les
chercheurs réalisent une toile sociale :
une représentation visuelle de tous les
liens sociaux de la colonie. Et ils
retrouvent que s'installer proches
d'individus apparentés réduit le stress.
Sauf peut-être quand on est à côté de sa mère.
Prochaine étape : Montrer comment ces
différents niveaux de stress impactent le
développement des jeunes et se
transmettre aux générations suivantes.
Et comme certains mécanismes liés au
stress sont similaires chez les
mammifères humains et non humains
voilà un projet de recherche qui
pourrait nous en apprendre beaucoup sur
nous mêmes.
C'est tout pour ce mini zeste
vous pouvez retrouver plus d'images de
ces créatures si mignonnes ainsi que la
méthodologie de cette étude dans le
reportage sur la chaîne du CNRS.
Je vous dis bon courage,  à bientôt.
N'oubliez pas
de mettre un pouce bleu,  de partager et
de vous abonner !